according to the history books Vlad
Dracula is killed by Ottoman troops in
1476 it is said he was beheaded but it
is still unknown exactly where he was
buried they can't help but wonder
someone so infamous and someone whose
tomb has never been found
could the satellite image could that
possibly be the undiscovered tomb of
Vlad and his court the shape of the
mounds does reflect one known ritual of
vampire burial in Transylvania vampire
lore and vampire burials are still very
common in the area there's a very strong
belief that vampires can rise from the
dead in order to prevent vampires from
returning
Transylvanian villagers turn their
graveyards into prisons for the undead
staking corpses in the heart or weighing
them down with stones there have been
graves that have been found with large
stones on top of the deceased to keep
them from rising from the dead to haunt
the living as vampires imagine laying
out a member of your family in a coffin
but then having to take the added
precaution
of driving a stake through their heart
covering the body with stones to prevent
them from rising again
could these huge mounds glimpsed in the
satellite image be massive stones or
piles of stone designed to weigh down
vampires these mounds are so huge if
there are any vampires down there
they're sure not going anywhere because
they weigh tons and tons the only way to
be certain is to investigate the site
thoroughly but that would require
centuries of superstition to be overcome
nobody has disturbed these mounds and
nobody seems to have the stomach to do
it I would love if this could be proven
to be the burial place of Vlad but it's
just screams of edition Cemetery a royal
cemetery the only way to unearth the
mystery of these mountains is to
excavate with proper archaeology until
that happens word is gonna be guessing